and we know Sharia law is popular in in
many more countries than you even named
I mean when I have liberals on the show
one of the big arguments is well you're
painting with a broad brush of course
Saudi Arabia's backwards but what about
Indonesia and Turkey and Jordan well I
looked up Indonesia and Turkey and
Jordan and well here are some of the
statistics here in Sharia law 72 percent
of Indonesians favorite Jordan 71
percent stoning of adulterers Indonesia
48 percent popular Jordan 67 percent
death for leaving Islam
Jordan 82 percent these are their
bastions of freedom and democracy how do
you how do we get liberals and some of
them are people I really used to respect
how do we get them to understand that
we're the Liberals in this debate yes
the people who are facing shining a
light on oppression and demanding that
it will and how can that not be the
liberal cause what do you say to
liberals I say to them that the cancer
of Islamic extremism is a an assault on
liberalism on liberal ideas right on the
idea of the human being as you know
protect the life of the human being the
freedom of the human the equality of
human beings that's what it is an
assault on Islamic extremists divide
them all into us and them and the ones
they deemed to be them even if they're
pious Muslims they kill them they
subjugate them they sell them into
slavery they rape the women and they
destroy arts and civilization and we and
we see it on a daily basis if you are a
liberal and you really truly believe in
the principles of liberalism you've got
to stand up to the challenge of the day
and that is Islamic extremism thank you
I am Holly you're my hero
all right